y aquellos de Uds. estudiantes de Tepper de atrás
estarán muy interesados en esto.
Así nos encontramos con que las contraseñas creadas
por las personas afiliadas a la escuela de ciencias de la computación
en realidad eran 1,8 veces más seguras
que las de los afiliados a la escuela de negocios.
Tenemos también información
demográfica muy interesante.
Otra cosa interesante que encontramos
es que al comparar las contraseñas de Carnegie Mellon
con las contraseñas generadas por Mechanical Turk,
había una gran cantidad de similitudes,
y así que esto ayudó a validar nuestro método de investigación
y mostrar que en realidad, la recogida de contraseñas
utilizando estos estudios de Mechanical Turk
es en realidad una forma válida para estudiar las contraseñas.
Así que fue una buena noticia.
Bien, quiero cerrar hablando de
algunas ideas que tuve durante mi año sabático
el año pasado en la escuela de arte de Carnegie Mellon.
Una de las cosas que hice
es una serie de edredones,
y he hecho este edredón de aquí.
Se llama "Manta de Seguridad".
(Risas)
Este edredón tiene las 1000
contraseñas robadas con más frecuencia
del sitio web RockYou.
El tamaño de las contraseñas es proporcional
a la frecuencia con que aparecían
en el conjunto de datos robados.
Lo que hice es crear esta nube de palabras,
y examiné todas las 1000 palabras,
y las categoricé en
categorías temáticas sueltas.
Y, en algunos casos,
era un poco difícil de entender
en qué categoría debían estar
y entonces las identifiqué por colores.
Así que estos son algunos ejemplos de la dificultad.
Digamos "justin".
¿Es ese el nombre del usuario,
su novio, su hijo?
Tal vez son un fan de Justin Bieber.
O "princesa".
¿Es un apodo?
¿Son fans de las princesas de Disney?
O tal vez ese es el nombre de su gato.
"Iloveyou" aparece muchas veces
en muchos idiomas diferentes.
Hay mucho amor en estas contraseñas.
Si miran atentamente, verán que hay también
algunas palabras soeces,
pero lo que fue realmente interesante ver para mí
es que hay mucho más amor que odio
en estas contraseñas.
Y hay animales,
una gran cantidad de animales,
y "mono" es el animal más común
y la 14 contraseña más popular.
Y esto fue realmente curioso para mí,
y me pregunté: "¿Por qué son tan populares los monos?"
Y así, en nuestro último estudio sobre contraseñas,
cuando detectamos que alguien
crea una contraseña usando "mono",
les preguntamos por qué tenían un mono en su contraseña.
Y lo que averiguamos...
encontramos 17 personas hasta el momento
que tienen la palabra "mono"...
Encontramos que un tercio de ellos dijo
que tienen una mascota llamada "mono"
o un amigo cuyo apodo es "mono"
y alrededor de un tercio de ellos dijo
simplemente que le gustan los monos
y que los monos son muy lindos.
Y ese joven es muy lindo.
Así, parece que al final,
cuando hacemos las contraseñas,
hacemos algo que o es muy fácil
de escribir, un patrón común,
o cosas que nos recuerdan a la palabra contraseña
o a la cuenta para la que hemos creado la contraseña,
o lo que sea.
O pensamos acerca de las cosas que nos hacen felices,
y creamos nuestra contraseña
basados en las cosas que nos hacen felices.
Y si bien esto facilita la escritura
y recordarla es más divertido,
también hace que sea mucho más fácil
descifrar la contraseña.
Así que sé que un montón de estas charlas TED
son fuente de inspiración
y hacen pensar sobre cosas agradables y felices,
pero cuando estén creando su contraseña,
traten de pensar en otra cosa.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)